you know this sunday will mark the one
year anniversary of the release
of avengers end game it would go on to
become
the biggest blockbuster in history but
boy has the world changed since then
not only for us but also the all-star
cast
can you say hi to the camera
i'm sort of just enjoying the time at
home with the kids and
and uh and not having a schedule laid
out in front of me
quarantine isn't turning chris back into
fat thor yeah remember that fat suit
instead the god of thunder is
homeschooling his kids and offering to
keep us
all in shape with his free workout app
since we can't get to the gym
it's kind of nice to be home you know i
don't miss the travel i miss this sort
of interaction with people certainly
but they're changing your time zones i'm
quite happy to do without
but just like every other work from home
parent there are challenges
check out chris's six-year-old son
crashing a recent interview
look he's looking at me right at the
moment i'm giving a little sort of
one of these ones sorry my son is
throwing pillows at the computer
oh and chris finally broke his silence
on his little brother's split from miley
when asked about liam's buff new body he
said it's australian living i guess
we got him out of malibu yeah no shade
there
now from the hemsworth brothers to the
evans clan chris has been social
distancing with his family
playing hide and seek with his nieces
and nephews and just hanging out
with dodger the dog all that family time
is where chris must have gotten the dad
thing down
he plays an attorney whose son is
accused of murder in his new series
defending jacob
premiering today on apple tv plus he's
my son
please don't arrest him andy please
but not every avenger's been as lucky
yeah wedding planning that's
a thing you're supposed to do it doesn't
just happen
scarlett johansson says she's looking
forward to seeing her five-year-old
daughter in a flower girl dress
whenever she finally gets to say i do to
colin jost
scarjo's expected final marvel feature
black widow was supposed to hit theaters
next week
but it's been pushed in november
meanwhile the shooting schedule for
spider-man 3
has been postponed indefinitely spidey
aka tom holland is on lockdown
in london with his brother and best
friends but he's still keeping in touch
with his fellow avengers
i actually facetimed downey a couple
days ago and he was in the bath
oh this is nice i spoke to uh jake
gyllenhaal the other day
we were talking about doing a peloton
class together
i'm here to attest that catherine's
banana bread
truly remarkable i love it star lords
chris pratt's been
living the newlywed life with his wife
catherine paul rudd and mark ruffalo
joined taika ytt in a covet 19 education
effort
and gwyneth oh she's getting her goop on
and doing face masks
all the avengers stars preparing for the
unknown of what's next
there's a bit of anxiety with that but
also kind of refreshing and so
it's trying to just be at peace with
that and just be in the moment
and to have a positive attitude